if you play CS2 stop scrolling the best
n in Counter Strike is back in CS go CTs
would famously throw this rant Molly
over the wall that would land here and
deter the te's from getting into
playground the problem is that in CS2
the lineups would either be too short
they would go too far or they would just
straight fizzle courtesy of the boy Rez
the Swedish Pro I'm going to show you
the new one you see this second Circle
right here and you see this one two this
second line right here what you're going
to do is you're going to meet on the two
of them like this you're going to keep
your Crosshair right there you're going
to run forward Crosshair on it at all
times and then right when you get to the
shadow of this lamp you are going to
jump
through what this is going to do is just
going to land deep and you can see that
even if the t's try to cross hugging the
left side it's still going to get them
you can throw this on the run super fast
and it doesn't take a lot of time so
throw this Molly the next time you're on
overpass and I promise it's going to be
60 seconds happy frag